hi
the second part of uh what i was talking
about with cytosensei and meeting him
and everything before
we all have memories and we see things
but our love for the art can sometimes
cloud
what we really think
most people that follow a master
will only look up to them and
put them on pedestals in their mind and
that they can never do it wrong
but they are human beings like anybody
else who said he was a human being
we bow to him with respect and that's
where it should
stop in my opinion
so following cytoscency
over the years he gained more and more
people on the mat
on his seminars people younger people
started
putting him on a pedestal running and
opening doors and
doing all sorts of things that
perhaps film stars and
people that get followed in that way
they start to be put on these
as i say these glorified pedestals that
they may not want but start to like
and i felt watching him that he started
to enjoy
this a lot
from time to time he would create more
ken and joe work and it was as if
oh i have to keep the crowds happy so i
must
develop more people will criticize me
for saying this but that's how i saw it
in the end there's so much to remember
in the cannon joe work that it was a
permanent challenge
trying to keep up to date
when i went to one i expected to see a
senses dojo what i did and the ginger
the spiritual area that i sent it built
everything was really run down it was
terrible really
in 1994 the gutters were leaking
water bowels overfilled
quite untidy
the dashes would have a bonfire in the
mornings
burning plastic completely
eco-non-friendly
and they would have this bonfire near
the washing line where we used to wash
our ghees and hang our geeses right
before the day's practice
you're only allowed to use the old
tumble dryer once a day
no what it wants to do once a week oh
well i can't remember that piece
but it was very run down
since he was the caretaker of the dojo
until he passed away
and that's what those senses wishes were
but sadly
he put none of the funds that he
received from the students back into the
property
he said it wasn't his property so it
wasn't his place to
keep it in good repair he was just there
to teach aikido
this i now see how it was
not really a very good way of looking
after our senses
place when he passed the
uishiba family
reclaimed the site they built a small
wall to divide
cytosenses small bungalow and land
off from the dojo area and i believe
it's still there today so now it's two
properties
they have spent a lot of time and money
making it
back into a beautiful surrounding
they've done it up in that gallery and
it is a
beautiful beautiful place to go and see
now and train at
it also took this for me to realize in
his passing
that i followed him around the world
and i followed him for his aikido and i
was blinded by
how much i wanted his aikido to not see
the person
and it's sad because when i see the
person
i see just another form of
giving the people that want the art
what they want but we paid dearly for it
since he started making his own weapon
scrolls
his own downgrade certification
you had to do a taijitsu downgrade level
through the different levels and then
you would have to do
weapon scrolls for those down levels as
well
there was five in all and
after i received my fourth one i was
offered my fifth
i said i couldn't afford it
because i just thought
i paid enough and i realized
that if sensei said i was good enough
then i was good enough but we are the
ones that
do the training we follow our teachers
but we pay daily for it we follow them
we give them all the hours the years
and they in return give us their
knowledge
but they are human beings and we're
human beings
and since his passing he's allowed me to
find myself
and to speak as i feel
i'm so pleased that louisa family have
taken the iwama dojo back
and have made in such a beautiful place
what i am sad about is that the teaching
now
is starting to become heavily towards
the same style store in tokyo
your walmart people have changed and
there aren't any
farmers and railway workers now
perhaps there's more academic people or
people that want the flowing stars
but i do believe that i sense his
martial art his buddha
the one that i believe works
still today as a martial art will be
lost and it will be lost
in time forever and those
people that do maa and bjj
will be correct we may not like
their style of martial arts but they
will be correct saying
aikido is of no use and will not work as
a martial art
if we lose the aikido scentsy
that he taught cydosensi and all the
things i've
praised cytosinchie for and the things
i've said against him
does not change the art the art should
be
kept and preserved and i'm hoping to do
that with many others
and i will be talking in the future
about my thoughts of the future
and the things that we should know the
technique should not
change even if we want to modify
the way we teach it thank you
if you have comments or questions
please leave them as normal and we'll
see if we can answer them
thank you